what's going on everybody yeah came back
welcome to part 2 of the JavaScript
basics tutorials in this part 2 we're
gonna continue working with the canvas
just really quickly just show some of
the other things that we can do and then
we're gonna get into functions so let's
go ahead an get started so let's say we
wanted to continue just drawing this you
know line so where we left off we have
this lovely piece of Contemporary Art
and if we wanted to we could just
continue drawing lines so for example
I'm just gonna copy these two lines we
don't need to move two because that's
all we did like we did that to like move
without actually drawing but if we
actually want to draw we just line two
and then stroke
so let's say we did I don't know 70 and
55 here if we rerun that you'll see okay
now we've got this you know angle added
but but what we're really interested in
is these blobs like I would really want
to know how do I draw like a blob and
what's a blob is a circle so so how do I
draw a circle to the to the canvas well
there's a method that is arc so in this
case we would contact context arc and
then the way that you look at this or
think about this is arc in theory if you
did a full arc it would be a full circle
so what would the center of this if
there if you did draw a full circle what
would the center be so in this case
we'll say a hundred a hundred now with
art you don't have to draw a circle so
arc is here for any time you want a
curved line right you you might want to
continue the curve all the way to make a
circle but you also just might want a
curved line so that's what arc kind of
solves all those things and one one fell
swoop so you would say what's the size
over sorry what's the location like the
XY 100 100 and then the next thing that
we would pass here is what's the size
and then you've got the starting angle
in the ending angle so we're gonna say
zero and then you would say basically
you're going to think of this in terms
of pies so one times a math dot pie is
going to be half of a circle
so let me just add a context dodge
stroke and let's go ahead and run that
and you'll see here so we drew two now
we didn't draw it like this doesn't go
to one hundred one hundred it's a bit
beyond that but the center of this
circle which would be like right there
that would be one hundred one hundred so
if we want to draw a full circle now
math dot pi we could say two times math
dot pi and we will run that and now we
have this full circle okay pretty cool
so now what I want to do is basically
all we actually want is to have a circle
for now so I'm going to delete
everything up to begin path we're going
to begin path we're on an arc the center
is here cool
and then we stroke so it's kind of like
you know this would be your line - and
then stroke so and then we don't need a
move - in this case so okay so let's
test that really quickly yes so now
that's a pretty boring blob we would
probably want to fill it so you can
probably I think you can get away with
this afterwards too you could do a
context fill after the stroke or before
the stroke I'm pretty sure yeah the
other thing that we can do is let me
just test this make sure yeah the other
thing that we can do is change the
actual color with context fill styles so
we can say context fill style and in
this case we'll go with a beautiful
green so now we get our green circle now
what if what if we wanted to have
multiple blobs like this how would we
actually do that and the way that we
would wind up doing that you know you
might think well I'll just haha I'll
just copy and paste I'm an expert
computer person and you you could do
that but you probably don't want to do
that right like we definitely just copy
and paste but that's
we use functions or at least things like
functions so like we used Verret we can
use variables to get rid of copying and
pasting to some extent mostly variables
is there so like if you needed to change
a value as you write you would just
change it in one location or you can use
variables if you want the program to
like change your value based on some
conditions with functions it's it is for
one it's just gonna clean up clutter and
stuff like that it's also going to make
it easier on the programmer because
imagine if you wanted to like change
these lines like like suddenly you just
let's just imagine you wanted to do
something different with how you get a
blob to the screen or what you're gonna
do with that blob or whatever now you've
got to come through to change every
single one of these it's a pain in the
butt and so anyway we definitely want to
use functions or something like
functions he will talk about classes in
a little bit not in this video so the
way that we're gonna do that is to with
a function we'll just come here and
let's just call this function we're
gonna call it blob and then you have
your parameters and then the function
itself now what does a blob take well a
blob is gonna take you know court like
it basically it's this stuff right here
we don't need to talk about the starting
in the ending angle here because we're
going to we're always going to use the
same values here it's always going to
make a full circle so we really just
want the X the Y size in the color so
that's exactly what I'm gonna write here
XY size color then what we want to do is
take this code here
and I'm just gonna cut it paste it then
I'm gonna highlight here and I am going
to I was gonna try to have that there we
go hit tab and tab it over so now that
we've done that the next thing is we
need to fix these variables in here so
like right now that's just hard coded
and this is part of what we wanted to
fix so we're actually just gonna pass X
Y
sighs and then in here we're gonna just
put color so now you've got this blob
function and now we actually want the
blob function to run so the way that we
could do that is just literally call
blob now sometimes you might write a
function that has no parameters right so
it looks like this and it does something
besides what we were just done here so
maybe these values are filled in right
and one of the common mistakes I see
from new programmers and myself included
I've made this mistake was you call blob
but you forget the parentheses or worse
in your actual you know definitions of
things you add parentheses which makes
it run so here this is just a pointer to
the blob function here this is running
the blob function okay so let me add
those bars back hopefully I could there
we go nice so now we want to actually
run the blob function so we are just
going to pass in let's do 25 100 size
will be 20 and color wool made green so
first let's just test to make sure that
works sure enough and now what I want to
do is close the towns if you use my
editor it would all be in the same tab
okay so this is that few more 75 and
we'll go with a 50 and then we'll put I
can't I'm not gonna make 5 of them but
we can do at least a few so we'll do 25
and then 100 and then this will be red
and then this one's blue and awesome we
were on it cool so that's that's
functions that's why we're doing it just
as a note don't forget to begin path if
we don't begin path like what if I took
this and just put it right out here let
me just run that real quick so you
notice how it looks pretty funky what's
going on there well begin path also
takes note of where not only where the
stroke is happening but for fill so the
last thing is gonna be filled here but
every step of the way so let me just
show one more thing
where I close out this tutorial so I
don't think we've talked about comments
so if we want to get rid of something or
we want to make a note to ourself like
you know makes a green blob we use
comments and the way you make a
single-line comment is with two forward
slashes and then the way you would make
a multi-line comment is with a slash and
then an asterisk and then multiple lines
and I guess I should make multiple lines
and there's an asterisk in a slash and
then I'll close it off now comments
aren't read by like JavaScript or
rendered by the browser or anything
they're there for either your notes or
so someone else reading your code gets a
better understanding of like what is
happening in your code and then so
basically pretty much those two things
either just a note to yourself later
like I want to add this or work on this
next or or you're telling yourself how a
function works or you know anything so
anyways but you can also use it for
debugging purposes like so in this case
I just wanted to show that the fill will
now be you know all read basically
everywhere because of what we've done
cool so yeah so the reason why I wanted
to show that is just just as a reminder
or not even really a reminder I haven't
really totally made it absolutely clear
I guess I did say begin pad starts and
restarts but keep that in mind it's not
just for a stroke it's for a fill it's
for everything going on so you
definitely want to make sure you re
beginpath
for every single blob or thing that you
draw to the canvas okay well I think
that we've made some really good
progress here we've got multiple blobs
on the screen the next thing we would
want to start doing is moving some blobs
right we want to get these blobs
animated and moving around and stuff and
bring them to life so in the coming
videos that's exactly what we're going
to be working on is how do we get these
to actually move around and all that if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
and a quick shout out to some of my
channel mem
Henry assumed our Rajneesh cheeky buns
13 and frank lloyd welcome back all of
you guys for your third months you guys
are amazing and that's it guys I will
see you guys in another video